हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल एंड वेलकम टू क्लास 49 एंड
वी आर नियर टू आवर हाफ सेंचुरी
तो फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
बताइए चैट में
यस या नो
ओके वेरी गुड गुड गुड इवनिंग सलमान एंड
फाइन सलमान मैं अच्छा हूं आप लोग बताइए आप
कैसे हो
और
हम जैसे कि आप सबको पता है कि हम अपनी हाफ
सेंचुरी कंप्लीट करने वाले हैं इस कोर्स
की बिल्कुल जगत गुरु जी हर हर महादेव एंड
अमन
अमन शेख यू आल्सो गुड इवनिंग
तो जल्दी हमारी हाफ सेंचुरी कंप्लीट हो
जाएगी और उसके बाद फिर हम सेंचुरी की तरफ
प्रोसीड करेंगे।
तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं स्टूडेंट्स का
और आज की क्लास मैं आपको बता देता हूं जो
यूएससी है जो क्लास नंबर फोर है यूएससी के
ऊपर हमारी फाइनल क्लास है। बिकॉज़
फंडामेंटल्स मैंने आपके क्लियर कर दिए
हैं। उसके बाद प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल हमारा
अभी चल रहा है। लास्ट क्लास में हमने
ग्राफिकल जीयूआई बेस्ड बाईपास देखा था।
अभी हमारा सीएलआई बेस्ड बाईपास बचा हुआ है
और उसके बाद हम इसको एंड कर देंगे और मैं
आपको बताऊंगा कि मैंने जैसे कि आपको बताया
भी था कि यूआई जो बाईपास टेक्निक्स है हम
कब यूज़ कर सकते हैं और कब यूज़ नहीं कर
सकते। एक बार फिर से मैं रिपीट कर दूंगा
इस चीज को बिकॉज़ इट इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट
चैलेंज फॉर एनी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग।
तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बताइए कि लास्ट
क्लास से रिलेटेड किसी का कोई भी डाउट है
तो अभी मुझसे पूछ सकते हो अगले 2 मिनट के
अंदर बिकॉज़ 2 मिनट के बाद हम क्लास को
स्टार्ट करेंगे। तब तक के लिए वेट करते
हैं कि बाकी और स्टूडेंट्स भी बाकी और
स्टूडेंट्स भी आ जाए।
कोई भी डाउट नहीं है। बिल्कुल क्लियर।
सबके डाउट बिल्कुल क्लियर है।
मेरी क्लास में किसी को डाउट आता ही नहीं।
क्या क्यों?
देखो डाउट क्लियर का मतलब यही है कि दो
तरीके से। या तो बिल्कुल ही समझ में नहीं
आया। ऊपर से गया या फिर कोई डाउट है ही
नहीं। अब कौन से वाला डाउट क्लियर है?
आई डोंट नो।
बताइए अभी हम बात कर सकते हैं 2 मिनट तक
क्योंकि अभी स्टूडेंट्स धीरे-धीरे बढ़ रहे
हैं।
इट्स ओके प्रणय अगर क्लास क्लास मिस हो गई
तो कोई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कवर कर लीजिए
क्योंकि हर एक क्लास का एक जो भी देखिए जो
पार्ट वन पार्ट टू में जो क्लासेस आती है
ना वो डिपेंडेंट होती हैं। बाकी जो भी
फर्दर क्लासेस आएंगी वह इंडिपेंडेंट भी
होती है क्योंकि वो कांसेप्ट और टॉपिक नया
होता है और अभी आने वाली क्लासेस तो और भी
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग क्लासेस रहेंगी ताकि
आप लोगों को थोड़ा सा और ज्यादा इंटरेस्ट
बने तो मुझे एक चीज बताइए आप लोग खास करके
जो अभी लाइव क्लास में हैं और जो या बाकी
वे स्टूडेंट्स जो बाद में क्लास एंड होने
के बाद रिकॉर्डिंग से क्लास को कवर करते
हैं। आप लोग भी चैट में बता सकते हो कि
मुझे यह बताइए कि आप लोग चाहते हो कि इस
डीईएई में भी वेब ऑलरेडी जो नितेश सर ने
बग बाउंट की जो सीरीज चलाई है बग बाउंट
सीरीज को कंप्लीट कर दिया है। क्या आप लोग
चाहते हो कि मैं भी वेब एप्लीकेशन
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग भी पढ़ाऊं डीएचई में
बिल्कुल फ्रॉम स्क्रैच टू एक लेवल इस जो
कोर्स के लेवल तक आप लोग चाहते हो
अगर आप लोग चाहते हो तो मैं स्टार्ट
करूंगा। बिकॉज़ आपको पता है मेरा तरीका
कैसा है पढ़ाने का। मैं ऐसे ही पढ़ाता हूं
धीरे-धीरे बट हम वेरी डिटेल्स में हम काफी
डिटेल में पढ़ेंगे। तो अगर आप लोग चाहोगे
तो हम क्लास को उसको भी कंटिन्यू करेंगे।
इसमें वेब एप्लीकेशन पेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग या
वेब एप्लीकेशन सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग की बात
करें वह भी हम कर सकते हैं। बट उसके लिए
वही है कि अगर मैंने एक बार स्टार्ट कर
दिया और आप लोग बोलो उसके बाद फिर आपका
रिस्पांस बिल्कुल ही जीरो रहे या क्लास का
रिस्पांस बिकॉज़ बहुत सारी चीजें तो नितेश
सर भी कवर कर चुके होंगे। तो कहीं आप
लोगों को लगे कि रिपीट हो रहा है तो क्यों
मैं इस क्लास को वह करूं कि करने की जरूरत
है।
ओके आपका नाम मुझे नहीं पता। आपने एक सवाल
पूछा कि सर मैं बीसीएस स्टूडेंट हूं और
मुझे साइबर सिक्योरिटी में जाना है तो 24
हावर्स में से कितना पढ़ पढ़ना पड़ेगा?
देखिए दोस्त बात ऐसी है कि डिपेंड करता है
कि आपका इंटरेस्ट क्या है कि अभी कोई
फोर्सफुली पढ़ने की कोशिश करेगा क्योंकि
यह कोई आईएएस आईपीएस की कोचिंग नहीं है
जहां पर कि आपको 18 घंटे पढ़ना पड़ेगा देन
उसके बाद कोई एग्जाम करोगे और बस लाइफ
सिक्योर क्योंकि देखो साइबर सिक्योरिटी एक
ऐसा फील्ड है आपको हर रोज अपडेट होना होगा
अपने आपको हर रोज अपडेट करना होगा नए-नए
टेक्नोलॉजी से, नए-नए टूल्स से, नए-नए
टैक्टिक्स से, नए-नए जो तरीके हैं मार्केट
में, नए-नए जो मालवेयर्स हैं या जो नए-नए
बग्स मिले हैं सबके साथ आपको अपडेट होना
पड़ेगा। साइबर सिक्योरिटी कोई एक
गवर्नमेंट जॉब की तरह नहीं है। कोई
एसएससी, कोई यूपीएससी, कोई आईएएस, आईपीएस
जिसमें आपने एक बार कुछ सालों तक बहुत
मेहनत की। उसके बाद एग्जाम क्रैक किया और
आपको एक पोस्ट मिल गई। उसके बाद आपको
पढ़ना नहीं पड़ेगा। साइबर सिक्योरिटी
फील्ड में हमेशा आपको सीखना पड़ेगा। हमेशा
आपको अपडेट रहना पड़ेगा। हमेशा कुछ ना कुछ
सीखते रहना पड़ेगा। क्योंकि डे बाय डे ईयर
बाय ईयर मंथ बाय ईयर मंथ आपकी जो
टेक्नोलॉजी है वो अपडेट होती है। अपग्रेड
होती है। सिस्टम्स चेंजेस होते हैं। उनके
वर्जनंस आते हैं। पुराने वर्जनंस काम करना
छोड़ चुके होते हैं। अपने आप को अपडेट
करना अपग्रेड करना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है।
इसी वजह से अगर आप यह सोच रहे हो कि सर 24
घंटे में से मैं 18 घंटे पढ़ता हूं एक साल
के लिए। उसके बाद मेरे को जॉब मिल जाएगी
और आई एम सिक्यर्ड माय लाइफ। तो ऐसा नहीं
है। साइबर सिक्योरिटी में आपको जब तक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में रहोगे आपको हमेशा
पढ़ना पड़ेगा। अंतर इतना रहेगा शुरुआत के
कुछ सालों में आपको बहुत ज्यादा मेहनत
करनी पड़ेगी। उसके बाद आपको पता है कि
बेसिक्स क्या है? आपको एक एडवांस आप
प्रोफेशनल हो। बट आपको पता है कि अभी क्या
चीज पढ़नी है। तो आपके लिए जो चीज आपको एक
वन मंथ लगती थी पढ़ने में वो आपको जस्ट वन
या टू हावर्स में आप उस चीज को देख लोगे।
कि इसका मतलब यह हो सकता है और ऐसे हम
अप्लाई कर सकते हैं। बट यह एक डार्क
रियलिटी है जो मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं।
तो अभी डिसीजन आपका है कि साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में जाना चाहते हो या नहीं
जाना चाहता चाहते। उसके बाद जाना चाहते हो
सोचिए। सोचने के बाद आप मैसेज कर दीजिए।
उस पे भी हम बात कर लेंगे। ओके?
बट स्पैम मत करो।
चलिए फिर क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं। जैसा
कि हमने लास्ट क्लास में आपको बताया था।
उसके ऊपर हमने आर्टिकल भी कवर कर लिया
अपना। तो यह आर्टिकल भी लिख दिया है मैंने
आप लोगों के लिए। आप क्या कर सकते हो?
यहां पर जाके इसको गो थ्रू कीजिए। उसको
पढ़िए। आपके जो भी डाउट्स हैं वो सारे के
सारे डाउट आपको
क्लास से रिलेटेड जो भी नोट्स आपको चाहिए
थे वो सारे डाउट इसमें भी क्लियर हो जाए।
क्योंकि जो कुछ मैंने पढ़ाया है सब कुछ
इसमें सब कुछ कवर कर दिया। थ्योरिटिकल
प्लस में प्रैक्टिकल्स के स्क्रीनशॉट सब
कुछ इसमें मैंने कवर कर दिया। जस्ट आप एक
काम कर सकते हो कि मेरी वीडियो को देखोगे।
देखने के बाद एक बार इस आर्टिकल को गो
थ्रू कीजिए। आपके डाउट परमानेंट क्लियर हो
जाएंगे रिलेटेड टू दिस पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक।
ओके?
देखो Android पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की
प्लेलिस्ट नहीं लेके आ सकते। एक प्लेलिस्ट
लेके आ सकता हूं। अगर कोशिश करूंगा तो
बिल्कुल बेसिक जिसका कोई फायदा नहीं
क्योंकि Android पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग मेरा
ही खुद का पेड कोर्स है। मैं ही पढ़ाता
हूं। हां आप चाहो तो वह ज्वाइन कर सकते हो
और उसको काफी डीप में टू 2.5 मंथ का कोर्स
होता है जिससे लाइव ट्रेनिंग है जिसे मैं
ही पढ़ाता हूं। आप वो ज्वाइन कर सकते हो।
पूरी Android पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग आपकी
कवर हो जाएगी।
तो चलिए फिर हम ये आपने आर्टिकल मिल गया
होगा। आर्टिकल अगर आपको आर्टिकल्स अच्छे
लग रहे हैं तो उस पे जाइए। वहां पर आप जो
मेरा मीडियम आर्टिकल्स को रीड कीजिए उस पर
कमेंट कीजिए। उसको शेयर कीजिए ताकि ज्यादा
से ज्यादा स्टूडेंट्स को इसके बारे में
नॉलेज मिले। उनको बार-बार नोट सर्च करने
की जरूरत ना पड़े। ओके? तो अगर आप नए
स्टूडेंट हो तो यहां पर आर्टिकल पे जाइए।
आर्टिकल को रीड कीजिए। रीड करके उसके बाद
इस पे कमेंट या इसको इसको भी आप
सब्सक्राइब कीजिए। क्योंकि यह क्या है?
ईमेल बेस्ड सब्सक्रिप्शन है। इससे क्या
होगा? जब भी मेरा कोई भी नया आर्टिकल आएगा
कभी भी तो आपको क्या होगा? इससे यह फायदा
होगा कि आपको सेम टाइम अपग्रेड मिल जाए कि
सचिन सर ने एक नया आर्टिकल ल्च किया है।
आपको वेट नहीं करना पड़ेगा किसी वीडियो का
किसी भी चीज का। ओके? तो चलिए हम सेशन को
कंटिन्यू करते हैं उस फिर डिस्कस करते हैं
एंड ऑफ द सेशन। आप बने रहिए। चलिए तो
सीएलआई बेस्ड यूएस बायपास के ऊपर हम बात
करने वाले हैं जो हमारा टॉपिक है। तो
देखते हैं। तो मैंने आपको बताया था कि जो
हम चैलेंज सॉल्व करने वाले हैं उसमें
ऑलरेडी अटैकर ने क्या किया? लोकल एनुमिशन
परफॉर्म किया है। लोकल एनिमरेशन परफॉर्म
करने के बाद अटैकर ने क्या फाइंड आउट किया
कि एक फूड हेलपर exc एक ऑप्शनल एक
प्रोग्राम था। एक बाइनरी थी जो हाई
इंटीग्रेटेड टोकन के साथ रन करती है। वह
उसने फाइंड आउट की कि इसको हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? एक्सप्लइट कर सकते हैं। इसके
थ्रू हम बाईपास कर सकते हैं। तो फूड
हेलपरexc है। यह प्रोग्राम था। इसके बारे
में मैंने आपको बताया था। यह क्या होता
है? किस पर्पस से इसका यूज़ किया जाता है?
यह एक ऑप्शनल फीचर्स को मैनेज करता है। यह
लास्ट क्लास में आपको कवर कर चुका हूं। तो
इसलिए मैं दोबारा इसको कवर नहीं करूंगा।
जस्ट स्लाइड में आप देख लीजिए। उसके बाद
मैंने बताया था कि जब हैकर्स ने जब
अटैकर्स ने फूड हेलपर exc को एग्जामिन
किया उसको एनालाइज किया तो उसने पाया कि
वो एक एच की करंट यूज़र्स की जो रजिस्ट्री
है उसमें कुछ क्यूरी कर रहा है। वहां पर
कोई फाइल है उसको ओपन करने की कोशिश कर
रहा है। बट वो फाइल अभी नहीं है। मतलब
वहां पर फाइल नेम नॉट फाउंड मतलब उसके लिए
एक अटैक सरफेस क्रिएट हो गया आपके लिए।
किसके लिए? अटैकर्स के लिए। यह उसकी
एनालिसिस है। देन हमने आपको यह भी बताया
था कि रजिस्ट्री से क्यों क्यूरी करती है।
क्योंकि जब भी आप किसी भी प्रोग्राम को
डबल क्लिक करते हो, किसी भी बाइनरी को ओपन
करते हो, किसी भी फाइल को ओपन करते हो तो
तो वह रजिस्ट्री के साथ कम्युनिकेट क्यों
करते हैं? उसका भी मैंने आपको कारण बताया
था। रजिस्ट्री आपका एक डेटाबेस होता है।
उस फाइल एसोसिएशन के लिए उससे क्वरी की
जाती है। क्योंकि इसी के बेस पे डिसीजन
लिया जाता है कि किट जेपीजी या.txt फाइल
है। उसको कौन सा प्रोग्राम रिस्पांसिबल है
ओपन करने के लिए। ये सब कुछ मैं आपको बता
चुका हूं। तो मैं इसको रिपीट नहीं करने
वाला। हम सीधा अपने प्रैक्टिकल में
चलेंगे। तो हमारा जो टारगेट हमारे पास जो
एक्सेस है इनिशियल एक्सेस हमें मिल गया
है। और सबको पता है कि अगर आपको यूएस के
को बाईपास करना है उसके लिए आपका सबसे
पहली जो कंडीशंस क्या है कि आपके पास
इनिशियल एक्सेस होना चाहिए। मतलब यह पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन का पार्ट है। ओके? पोस्ट
एक्सप्लटेशन में प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन जो
स्टेप थ्री या फोर्थ है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन फेज का उसका यह एक पार्ट
है। उसके बाद सेकंड कंडीशन यह है कि आपका
जो यूजर अकाउंट है वो लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप का पार्ट होना चाहिए। अदरवाइज आप
यूएसी प्र्प को बायपास नहीं कर पाओगे। यह
दो कंडीशंस मैंने आपको बताई थी। उसके बाद
हमारा जो टारगेट है, आपको टारगेट मैंने
बता चुका हूं कि fूlper.exc में यहां पर
यह हमारा टारगेट है। चलिए, प्रैक्टिकली भी
देखेंगे। मैं आपको समझाता हूं। तो मैंने
एक चीज बताई थी जब भी आप क्या करोगे जब भी
आप इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन करते हो विंडोज
सिस्टम पर सबसे पहला आपका काम है यह चेक
करना यूएस के केस में कि आप जो एज ए
यूज़र्स कि आप कोई एडमिन यूजर हो या नहीं
हो या क्या आप लोकल एडमिनिस्टर ग्रुप का
पार्ट हो या नहीं हो यह चीज आपका काम है
फाइंड आउट करना यह कुछ कमांड्स है आप रन
कर सकते हो हु एम आई नेट यूजर अटैकर्स सो
ऑन सो यह हम करके परफॉर्म करके दिखाएंगे
तो नेक्स्ट सबसे पहले ट्रिक यूज़ करने वाले
हैं हम सीएलआई बेस्ड यूएससी बाईपास
टेक्निक। तो हम सबसे पहले क्या करने वाले
हैं? हमें पता है कि हमारा टारगेट क्या
है? तो हम क्या करेंगे? जो रजिस्ट्री है
उसमें मॉडिफिकेशन करेंगे। उसमें क्या
करेंगे? उस रजिस्ट्री को अब्यूज करेंगे।
जिस लोकेशनेशंस पे वो क्यूरी कर रहा था।
यहां पर ये रहा। यह लोकेशन थी। इस लोकेशन
पे हम क्या करेंगे? अपनी जो मशियस फाइल है
जो हम रन करवाना चाहते हैं जो भी हम
सीएमडी रन करवाना चाहते हैं या जो हम
मिलेशियस फाइल रन करवाना चाहते हैं वो हम
इस लोकेशन पर क्या कर देंगे रख देंगे वो
कैसे रख सकते हैं अभी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
हम वो भी कमांड लाइन हेल्प की हेल्प से भी
कर सकते हैं सीएमडी की हेल्प से उसके लिए
भी कमांड्स होती है उन कमांड्स का मैं
आपको परफॉर्म करके दिखाने वाला हूं देखिए
एक चीज है Windows Windows में आपको कोई
भी आईडिया नहीं होता कि सीएमडी कैसे हैंडल
की जाती है। आपको इतनी कमांड्स की आईडिया
नहीं होता। मैं आपको क्या कर रहा हूं कि
कमांड्स रन करके दिखाता हूं और कमांड्स का
पर्पज भी एक्सप्लेन करता हूं। उसके बाद
आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होती है क्योंकि
आपको पता चल गया कि हमारी रिक्वायरमेंट
क्या है? अगर मुझे Windows पेन टेस्टिंग
करनी है। अगर उसकी सीएमडी को यूज़ करना है
तो मुझे उसकी कमांड्स पता होनी चाहिए।
उसकी कमांड्स की चेक ऑफ लिस्ट मेरे पास
होनी चाहिए। तो यह आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
है। उनको सर्च करके उस कमांड की लिस्ट को
कलेक्ट करना और अपने पास सेफली रखना। सो
दैट जब भी आप पेन टेस्टिंग करो तो आप
डायरेक्टली उस कमांड को देखो और रन कर
पाओ। अदरवाइज क्या कमांड्स कभी भी याद
नहीं होती। यूज़ करते-करते याद होती है।
लेकिन आप रोज-रोज़ तो Windows पेन टेस्टिंग
नहीं करते बिकॉज़ यू आर नॉट ए ऑफिशियल पेन
टेस्टर। अगर आप किसी इंडस्ट्री में डेली
Windows को यूज़ कर रहे हो वाया कमांड
लाइन। अगर आप आईटी एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स हो तो
आपको पता है कि कौन-कौन सी कमांड किस चीज
के रिस्पांसिबल है। क्योंकि जो रजिस्ट्री
डेटाबेस है उसको भी हम कमांड से एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं। तो सबसे पहले हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? फर्स्ट कमांड जो रन करेंगे वह है सेट
रजिस्ट्री की इक्वल वह पाथ आपके फुल
रजिस्ट्री का पाथ एच की करंट यूजर
सॉफ्टवेयर क्लासेस एमएस सेटिंग सेल ओपन
सीएमडी अभी यहां पर क्या कर रहा है जो सेट
कमांड क्या करती है सेट असाइन एन
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल जो सेट कमांड होती है
एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल क्या करती है असाइन
करती है क्रिएट करती है तो एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल का नाम क्या है रजिस्ट्री की ये
ये आपका एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल है दी वेरिएबल
रेग की विल होल्ड द एंटायर रजिस्ट्री
पार्ट पाथ। अभी जो यह एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल
है, इसके अंदर क्या है? आपकी जो पूरी
रजिस्ट्री जो आपने पाथ मेंशन किया है ना,
इसका पूरे उस इस पूरी रजिस्ट्री का पाथ का
रेफरेंस है। किसके अंदर? इस एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल के अंदर। अगर हम जब इसको यूज़ करना
चाहते हैं इस वेरिएबल को, तो हम कैसे यूज़
करेंगे? जब भी परसेंटेज
वेरिएबल नेम परसेंटेज और जब भी जहां पे यह
यूज़ करेंगे तो इसका मतलब क्या है कि हम इस
फुल पाथ को यूज़ कर रहे हो। तो पहली कमांड
का मतलब है कि हमने एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल
क्रिएट किया। उस वेरिएबल की वैल्यू में
हमने क्या किया? एक पूरी रजिस्ट्री का फुल
पाथ हमने सेव किया। सेकंड कमांड हम यूज़
करने वाले हैं सेट सीएमडी। सेम उसके अंदर
भी हम क्या करने वाले हैं? एक पावर सेल
विंडोज स्टाइल हिडन ये पूरी कमांड मैं
आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा। इस हम क्या कर रहे
हैं? एक और एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल क्रिएट कर
रहे हैं। उसके अंदर हम अपना कमांड सेव कर
रहे हैं। तो इस ये कमांड क्या-क्या कर रही
है? देखिए सेट असाइन एन एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल। जो सेट कमांड है, ये क्या कर रही
है? आपकी एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल को असाइन कर
रही है। दी वेरिएबल सीएलडी इसके अंदर क्या
है? एक कोटेड स्ट्रिंग है। उसके अंदर क्या
है? आपके कुछ कोई कमांड रन कर रही है। कोई
पावर सेल की कमांड है। कोई कोड रन कर रहा
है इसके अंदर। मतलब जो सीएमडी एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल है उसके अंदर यह पूरा कोड है। और
इसको अगर एक्सपेंड करना है, इसको यूज़ करना
है, तो हम परसेंटेज सीएमडी परसेंटेज का
यूज़ करेंगे। अभी पावर सेल का मतलब क्या
है? पावर सेल ल्च द पावर सेल इंटरप्रेटर।
पावर सेल जो कमांड है इसका मतलब है कि जब
हम पावर सेल लिखेंगे तो हम पावर सेल
इंटरप्रेटर का यूज कर रहे हैं। पावर सेल
का यूज कर रहे हैं। देन उसके बाद हफन
विंडो स्टाइल हिडन। इसका मतलब क्या है? इट
टेल्स पावर सेल टू रन विदाउट शोइंग ए
विंडो साइलेंट एग्जीक्यूशन। इसका मतलब
क्या है? कि जो ये ऑप्शन हम यूज़ कर रहे
हैं विंडो स्टाइल हिडन। यहां पर इसका मतलब
यह है कि जो पावर सेल इस जो कमांड को रन
करे ना उसके लिए आपको कोई भी विंडो शो ना
करे। साइलेंटली एग्जीक्यूट होने यूजर को
पता नहीं होना चाहिए। सी टूल सॉकेट सॉकेट
exc यह आपका एक टूल होता है। एक बाइनरी
बाइनरी है सॉकेट.x एक सॉकेट बाइनरी है।
उसका यहां पर यहां पे इस जो मशीन है
टारगेट मशीन उसके अंदर एक एग्जीक्यूटेबल
पहले से ही रख दिया टेस्टिंग पर्पस के लिए
आप ताकि आपको फाइल ट्रांसफर ना करनी पड़े
ताकि आपका जो प्रैक्टिकल है स्मूथली रन
करे। तो इसके लिए क्या किया?
exc की जो एक जो एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल है
उसको इस लोकेशन पर रखा गया है। इस फुल पाथ
को हमने यहां पर मेंशन किया है। देन शोकट
क्या है? शोकट इज ए लेजिटमेट नेटवर्क लेयर
रिले एंड मल्टीप्लेक्स फ्लेक्सर टूल
सिमिलर टू netcat बट मोर कैपेबल। यह नेटकट
की तरह ही है। बट उससे बहुत ज्यादा
पावरफुल और कैपेबल है। इट कैन कनेक्ट टू
एंड पॉइंट एंड फॉरवर्ड डेटा बिटवीन देम।
यह क्या करता है कि दो एंड पॉइंट्स हैं
उनको कनेक्ट करता है और उनके बीच में क्या
करता है? डेटा ट्रांसमिशन का काम करता है।
चाहे कोई भी फाइल ट्रांसफर करनी हो, कोई
टीसीपी हो, टीसीपी कनेक्शन या यूडीपी
कनेक्शन क्रिएट करना हो या स्टैंडर्ड
इनपुट आउटपुट मतलब कोई कमांड भेजनी है,
कोई कमांड रिसीव करनी है या कोई प्रोसेस
एग्जीक्यूट करनी है। ये सारी चीजें क्या
करता है? यह रिमोट एक रिमोटली काम करता
है। एक प्रकार से एक रिमोट क्रिएट कर देता
है एक मशीन से दूसरी मशीन के साथ। मतलब
एंड टू एंड इसका पर्पस यह है। इस पर्पस से
हम क्या कर सॉकेट extxc को यूज़ कर रहे
हैं। यह आप जब Google करोगे Google पे
आपको यह मिल जाएगा। देन टीसीp मतलब यहां
पर इसका मतलब क्या है? हम टीसीp कनेक्शन
क्रिएट करना चाहते हैं। अटैकर आईपी मतलब
इसके अंदर आप क्या करोगे? आपका जो काली
लinक्स का मशीन है जो आपकी काली लinक्स है
उसका आईपी एड्रेस। लोकल आईपी एड्रेस यहां
पर क्या करोगे? आप असाइन करोगे।
फोर टाइम्स फोर क्या है? आपका वह पोर्ट
नंबर जिससे आपका कनेक्शन बेस आपका रिवर्स
कनेक्शन बनेगा। उस पोर्ट से उसका पोर्ट
नंबर यहां पर सोकेट वुड अटेमप्ट टू कनेक्ट
आउट टू दैट रिमोट होस्ट एंड पोर्ट अब यह
क्या है यह रहा फिर उसके बाद एग्जैक्ट ठीक
है सॉकेट का आपको पर्पस मैंने बता दिया
एग्जैक्ट क्या करता है एग्जीक्यूशन टेल्स
सॉकेट टू एग्जीक्यूट ए लोकल प्रोग्राम एंड
कनेक्ट इट्स इनपुट आउटपुट टू द नेटवर्क
सॉकेट मतलब यह इसका मतलब क्या है कि यह
सॉकेट को बोल रहा है कि एक लोकल प्रोग्राम
एग्जीक्यूट करना है और आपका जो इनपुट
आउटपुट है जो नेटवर्क सॉकेट का उसके के
साथ उसको कनेक्ट करना है। बेसिकली आप यहां
पर क्या कर रहे हो? एक सेल ओपन कर रहे हो।
तो cmd.xe क्या है? Windows का कमांड
इंटरप्रेटर है। आपने क्या कर लिया? एक
मशीन से दूसरी मशीन के बीच में एक एंड
पॉइंट क्रिएट कर लिया। उस एंड पॉइंट के
थ्रू आप क्या कर रहे हो? सेल का कनेक्शन
क्रिएट कर रहे हो। तो पाइप क्या करता है?
टेल सॉकेट यूज़ पाइप टू कम्युनिकेट विद द
स्पॉन प्रोसेस। तो बिल्कुल पूरी डिटेल्स
में इस कमांड को मैंने एक्सप्लेन कर दिया
है और जितना पॉसिबल हो सकता है कि आज या
कल दोपहर तक इसके ऊपर भी आपका डिटेल
आर्टिकल आ जाएगा एज इट इज सो दैट कि आप
इसको भी कवर कर पाओ विदाउट एनी ट्रबल। तो
उसके बाद यह दो कमांड हो गई। यह क्या कर
रहा है यहां पर जो पावर सेल है एक सॉकेट
exc जो अह जो जो एग्ज़क्यूटबल उसको ल्च कर
रहा है। ल्च करने के बाद जो सॉकेट है एक
टीसीपी कनेक्शन ओपन कर रहा है। टीसीp
कनेक्शन ओपन करके पोर्ट नंबर 44 44 44 के
साथ क्या कनेक्शन क्रिएट कर रहा है
एक्सटर्नल होस्ट के साथ। उसके बाद cmd डॉट
exc को रन करके एक कनेक्शन क्रिएट कर रहा
है रिमोटली किसी दूसरी मशीन। बेसिकली क्या
कर रहा है कि आप Windows से आपकी जो अटैकर
मशीन है जो काली लinक्स है उसके साथ क्या
कर रहे हो? आप एक कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश कर
रहे हो। एक रिमोट कनेक्शन आप क्रिएट कर
रहे हो। तो उसके बाद आपकी थर्ड कमांड है
रेज ऐड ये। इसको भी एक्सप्लेन करता हूं।
इसका मतलब क्या है? तो रेज ऐड दिस इज़ अ
Windows कमांड यूज्ड टू ऐड और मॉडिफाई ए
रजिस्ट्री वैल्यू। अगर आप अपने अगर आपको
अपनी रजिस्ट्री की वैल्यू को या तो
मॉडिफाई करना है कोई नई वैल्यू ऐड करनी है
तो आपको इस कमांड का यूज करना पड़ता है
Windows के अंदर। इट अलाउड यू टू क्रिएट
न्यू एंट्रीज और एडिट एकिस्टिंग वन इन द
Windows रजिस्ट्री। बिल्कुल आप या तो कोई
नई एंट्री क्रिएट कर सकते हो या जो पहले
से एग्जिस्ट करती है उसको क्या कर सकते
हो? एडिट कर सकते हो। परसेंटेज रेज की
परसेंटेज यह एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल जो
आपको पता है जो हमने सेट कमांड की हेल्प
से सेट किया था। उसके अंदर किसकी वैल्यू
है? इस रजिस्ट्री की वैल्यू है। यहां पर
हमने उसको रेफर किया, एक्सपेंड कर लिया।
उसके बाद हफन वी हफन वी कॉलन डेलीगेट
एग्जीक्यूट ये क्या है? दी हफन वी ऑप्शन
स्पेसिफाई द नेम ऑफ द वैल्यू यू वांट टू
क्रिएट और मॉडिफाई। मतलब क्या है? कि किस
नाम से आप वो वैल्यू ऐड करना चाहते हो उस
रजिस्टर के अंदर या मॉडिफाई करना चाहते हो
वो वैल्यू यहां पर आप डबल कोट के अंदर
मेंशन करते हो। हियर द वैल्यू बीइंग
क्रिएट इज़ नेम डेलीगेट एग्जीक्यूट। उसका
मतलब उसका नाम क्या है यहां पर? डेलीगेट
एग्जीक्यूट। ईच रजिस्ट्री की कैन कंटेन
मल्टीपल नेम्ड वैल्यूज़ एज वेल एज ए
डिफ़ॉल्ट अननेम्ड वैल्यू वंस। एक रजिस्टर
के अंदर मल्टीपल्स नेम्ड वैल्यू भी हो
सकती है या अननेम्ड वैल्यू भी हो सकती है।
जिसको हम डिफ़ॉल्ट वैल्यू भी बोलते हैं।
हफन डी ऑप्शन क्या कर रहा है? दी हफन डी
ऑप्शन स्पेसिफाई द डेटा दैट शुड बी स्टर्ड
इन द वैल्यू। आपने वैल्यू तो क्रिएट कर ली
लेकिन इस इसके अंदर किस टाइप का आप डेटा
स्टोर करना चाहते हो? आपने यहां पर क्या
एम्प्टी छोड़ दिया। आप इसके अंदर कोई भी
डेटा स्टोर नहीं करना चाहते। आप इसको
एंप्टी रखना चाहते हो। हफन एफ फ्लैग क्या
कर रहा है? फोर्स दी कमांड एग्जीक्यूट
विदाउट आस्किंग फॉर कंफर्मेशन एंड ओवराइट
एनी एग्जिस्टिंग वैल्यू विद द सेम नेम। यह
क्या कर रहा है? फोर्स का इसलिए यूज़ किया।
अगर इस नाम से कोई वैल्यू एग्ज़िस्ट करती
है उस रजिस्टर के अंदर, तो फोर्सफुली उसको
क्या कीजिए? ओवराइट कीजिए या फिर अगर
डेलीगेट एग्जीक्यूट नाम से कोई भी कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट
कोई भी रजिस्ट्री वैल्यू एग्जिस्ट नहीं
करती तो नई क्रिएट कीजिए। इसका मतलब यह
है। तो ये कमांड भी शायद सबको समझ में आ
गई होगी। क्लियर है यहां तक जितनी भी
कमांड मैंने बताई तीन कमांड तीनों कमांड
क्लियर है गाइज़?
सबको क्लियर है? जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स यहां
पर अवेलेबल है, सबको क्लियर है?
बिल्कुल क्लियर है। तो बताओ
तो बहुत बढ़िया। तो नेक्स्ट कमांड आपकी
क्या रहेगी? इस कमांड का पर्पज आपको पता
चल गया। एक्सप्लेन करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
नेक्स्ट कमांड आपकी रहेगी रजिस्ट्री ऐड यह
वाली। इस कमांड को मैं एक्सप्लेन करता
हूं। तो आपको सबको पता है रजिस्ट्री ऐड का
मतलब क्या है? कि आप रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
कुछ भी मॉडिफिकेशन या कोई वैल्यू ऐड कर
रहे हो।
परसेंट परसेंटेज रैक की का मतलब क्या है?
इसके अंदर यह वैल्यू है। परसेंटेज सीएमडी
का मतलब इसके अंदर आपकी वो पावर सेल वाली
कमांड थी जिसके अंदर वो डेटा था। हफन डी
का मतलब क्या कर रहे हो आप? यहां पर देखो
हफन डी का मतलब यहां पर क्या कर रहे हो आप
उस वैल्यू को असाइन कर रहे हो किसके अंदर
ठीक है आप एक ऐड कर रहे हो रजिस्ट्री ऐड
आपने क्या किया एमएस सेटिंग सेल ओपन कमांड
जो रजिस्ट्री है यहां पर जो कमांड है इसकी
वैल्यू सेट कर रहे हो ये रही पावर सेल
विंडो स्टाइल हिडन उसके बाद आप हफन वी यूज़
नहीं कर रहे हो अभी हफन वी क्यों यूज़ नहीं
कर रहे इसका मतलब क्या है कि आप डिफॉल्ट
वैल्यू के अंदर स्टोर करना चाहते हो दिस
टाइम वी नॉट यूज़ हफन वी मींस मींस इट इज़
नॉट राइटिंग टू ए नेम्ड वैल्यू लाइक
डेलीगेट एग्जीक्यूट इट राइटिंग टू द
डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू ऑफ़ द की इन रजिस्ट्री
एडिटर दिस इज़ द लाइन यू सी लेबल्ड एज
डिफॉल्ट जब आप हफन वी का यूज़ नहीं करते तो
जब भी कोई डेटा आप सेट करोगे पर्टिकुलर
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर तो वो डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू
के अंदर स्टोर होगा। हफन ऐप का मतलब फोर्स
वही सेम अगर पहले से कोई कमांड आपने देखी
थी ये एच एचके सीयू सॉफ्टवेयर क्लास एमएस
सेटिंग सेल ओपन वहां पर नेम नॉट फाउंड आया
था अगर वहां पर अगर कोई वैल्यू भी है तो
उसको भी क्या करो फोर्सफुली रिप्लेस कर दो
अदरवाइज जो मैंने कमांड बताई है पावर सेल
विंडो स्टाइल हिडन टूल सॉकेट excp अटैकर
आईपीए इसको क्या कर दो आप एग्जीक्यूट करो
समझ में आ गया यह है इसका मतलब यह क्लियर
है सबको? यह वाली कमांड क्लियर है एवरीवन?
लास्ट वाली कमांड
बताइए। यही कमांड है सबको क्लियर।
प्रैक्टिकली दिखाऊंगा। डोंट वरी। चिंता
करने की बिल्कुल भी जरूरत नहीं है। तो
चलिए ये थी आपकी कमांड। नेक्स्ट। तो हमने
क्या किया? प्रैक्टिकली इन कमांड्स को ऐसे
रन किया। तो नाउ व्हनेवर सम टाइम समथिंग
ट्रिगर एमएस सेटिंग इसका मतलब यह है कि जब
हमने यह अपना सेटअप यह सारी कमांड हमने रन
कर दी तो इसका मतलब है कि जब भी कोई भी
फूड हेलपर डॉट exc कमांड को रन करेगा तो
हमारा पे लोड एग्जीक्यूट होगा हमारा पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूट होगा क्योंकि डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू
के अंदर क्या है हमारी कमा cmdx जो पावर
सेल वाली कमांड है तो उसके लिए हमारी
कंडीशंस क्या है हमें क्या करना है सबसे
पहले नेट कैट लिसनर रन करना है पोर्ट नंबर
ट्रिपल फोर टाइम्स फोर पे सेकंड आपको क्या
करना है फूड हेलपर exc को मैनुअली
एग्जीक्यूट करना है क्योंकि आपके पास सेल
एक्सेस है यह दोनों काम हो जाए तब क्या
होगा आपको सेल मिल जाएगा सक्सेसफुली आप
क्या कर पाओगे आपको सेल एक्सेस मिल जाएगा
वह भी हाई मैंडेटरी लेवल के साथ चलिए मैं
आपको प्रैक्टिकली दिखा देता हूं तो
प्रैक्टिकली देखने के लिए हम एक काम करते
हैं अपनी मशीन पर चलते हैं यह रहा
एंटर यह रहा। तो ऑलरेडी हमारा कनेक्शन
क्रिएट हो जाएगा। अभी एक काम करते हैं। यह
रहा कनेक्टेड है। उसके बाद यह रहा यह
ट्राई करते हैं कनेक्ट करने की। तो हमारे
पास फॉर एग्जांपल वही कंडीशन वही है कि
हमारे पास उसका एक्सेस मिल गया है मशीन
का। तो एक काम चेक करते हैं। नाउ
कनेक्टिंग टू रिमोट मशीन। नाउ नाउ कनेक्ट
कनेक्ट।
बिकॉज़ ट्राई हैक पे लैब है। प्रीमियम लैब
है। तो इट इज वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग लैब बिकॉज़
यह सब कुछ इधर भी था। बट सम टाइम सम टाइम
समटाइम मशीन ऑलरेडी स्टार्टेड है। तो
व्हाट इज द इशू दैट? कनेक्टिंग टू द रिमोट
कनेक्शन एंड
कंट्रोल सी
इट इज ट्रेकिंग। एक काम करते हैं हम इसको
दोबारा से टर्मिनेट करके दोबारा ऑन करते
हैं। चलो।
टर्मिनेट द मशीन फिर से हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
मशीन को इट विल टेक टाइम
तो बहुत सारे स्क्रीनशॉट्स कुछ इधर से भी
लिए गए हैं। टेक्निक्स कुछ इधर से भी ली
गई है। इसका कारण है क्योंकि इससे बेस्ट
प्रैक्टिकल लैब अवेलेबल नहीं है क्योंकि
खुद की लैब सेटअप करना इतना आसान नहीं है।
इतना जल्दी पॉसिबल नहीं कि नेक्स्ट क्लास
आपकी लेनी है और इतना जल्दी सेटअप कर
पाएं। इसीलिए मैक्सिमम कंटेंट इधर से लिया
गया है। बट इसको मैंने ज्यादा एक्सप्लोर
किया है। अदरवाइज खुद के एग्जांपल तो है
ही। वह तो हम कर सकते हैं। बट इससे क्या
है कि आपको एक आईडिया मिलेगा डिटेल्स में
कि हम क्या करना है हमें। ओके
अभी अभी पता नहीं व्हाट हैपन व्हाट इज द
प्रॉब्लम विथ दैट
एंड एंड एंड एंड एंड एंड
अरे यार
पता नहीं कोई प्रॉब्लम है इन के साथ
हम
यस परफेक्ट फाइन चलिए कंट्रोल सी नाउ
किसी को कोई आईडिया है कि हमें
हमारी ये काली नेक्स्ट जो लेटेस्ट वाली
प्रॉब्लम क्या है? किसी को कोई भी आईडिया
है?
लो भैया यह हो गई प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट।
नॉट कनेक्टिंग टू आवर मशीन
और हमारा एग्जांपल धरा का धरा रह जाएगा।
ओ हो यह होती है प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट जब समय
से
के लिए आपका
कोई सवाल है तो मुझसे पूछ के देखिए। जी
चलो मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं। देखो
लास्ट में बताने के बजाय यूएस बायपास की
टेक्निक
अगर आपको अप्लाई करनी है। दो कंडीशन मैं
आपको बता चुका हूं। लेकिन उससे पहले आपके
पास इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए। इंफॉर्मेशन
क्या? किस टाइप की मशीन है? Windows है,
लinक्स है, कौन सा वर्जन है? उसके बाद
आपके पास एक्सेस एडमिन लेवल होना चाहिए।
उसके बाद सबसे मोस्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन होनी
चाहिए आपके पास जो मैंने आपको कांसेप्ट
बताया था। क्या कांसेप्ट आपको एक्सप्लेन
किया था? कांसेप्ट यह था कि कौन सा
कांसेप्ट था सबको पता है ना? कि इन हाई
इंटीग्रिटी लेवल मतलब सिस्टम में बहुत
सारी ऐसी प्रोसेससेस होती है सिस्टम्स की
बाइनरीज होती हैं जो सिस्टम लेवल टास्क
परफॉर्म करती है ऑटोमेटिकली बिना किसी
यूएस प्र्ट के तो आपके पास वो इंफॉर्मेशन
होनी चाहिए कि कौन सी प्रोसेस कौन सी
बाइनरी हाई एलिवेटेड प्रोसेस के साथ रन कर
रही है और
उसमें क्या कमी हो सकती है जिसे आप बाईपास
कर सकते हो सभी को नहीं बाईपास कर सकते
क्योंकि और दूसरी दूसरी चीज एक और है कि
कुछ ऐसी प्रोसेससेस भी बाइनरी है जो सिर्फ
जीयूआई पे काम करती है। ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरस्ट पे ही काम करती है। सीएलआई से
इंटैक्ट नहीं करती। तो आपको कौन सी
प्रोसेस चाहिए? हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल वाली।
साथ में जो सीएलआई से भी इंटैक्ट करे
जिसके साथ आप इंटैक्ट कर पाओ। कुछ
मॉडिफिकेशन कर पाओ। इन सारी कंडीशन के बाद
ही आप बायपासिंग यूएसए वाले टेक्निक को
अप्लाई कर सकते हो। अदरवाइज यू कैन नॉट
बायपास। यू कैन नॉट अप्लाई बिकॉज़ आपके पास
जब इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है, यह सारी चीजें
आपके पास नहीं है, तो फिर
कोई फायदा नहीं है बाईपासिंग यूएस सोचने
का कि आप उसका जो यूएसm मी वाला जो टूल
होता है जो आपको मैं बताऊंगा कि उसको
डायरेक्टली आप रन करोगे और आप बाईपास कर
पाओगे। ब्लाइंडली आप बाईपास नहीं कर सकते
क्योंकि आपके विदाउट एनी इंफॉर्मेशन यू
कैन नॉट डू एनीथिंग इन Windows। ओके? तो
यह आप ट्रिक समझिए। आपको आप यह आपके लिए
बोल सकते हो ट्रिक या टेक्निक सोचिए या
आपके लिए मेरी तरफ से एक टिप थी कि
यह कंपलसरी कंडीशंस हैं। अगर कोई यह बोलता
कि इन कंडीशंस के अलावा बाईपास कर सकते हो
तो हो सकता है कोई मुझसे बड़ा पेंटस्टर्स
हो। बहुत सारी हो सकते हैं। आई एम नॉट ए
बिग बेंटेस्टर्स बट कोई मुझसे ज्यादा
पेंटस उसको मुझसे ज्यादा नॉलेज हो तो
मोस्ट वेलकम वो इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर कर सकता
है।
लाइव में वैसे बहुत कम स्टूडेंट्स आते
हैं। पता नहीं व्हाट इज द प्रॉब्लम विद
दैट गाइस। चलो इसको ओके इसको मैं पिक कर
देते हैं। इसको मिनिमाइज कर देता हूं।
आईपी कॉपी कर लेते हैं। IP हमने कॉपी
किया। इसको मिनिमाइज कर देते हैं। यहां पर
अभी कॉपी करने कंट्रोल एन सी
कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश करते हैं। और हमारा
कनेक्शन हो गया। देखिए अब हम उसी कंडीशंस
में हैं। उसी फेज में है जब हमें क्या
चाहिए? रिमोट एक्सेस चाहिए। ठीक? मतलब जब
हमें इनिशियल गेन एक्सेस कर लिया और हमें
यह चेक करना है कि क्या हम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप का पार्ट हैं या है? नहीं। तो सबसे
पहले हमारी कमांड होगी हु एम आई। हमने चेक
किया तो माय सर्वर अटैकर। चलिए उसके बाद
हम क्या करेंगे? नेट यूजर
अटैकर
हमें चेक करना है। उसके बाद फाइंड कमांड
का यूज़ करेंगे। फाइन देन
लोकल ग्रुप
हिट एंटर तो वी आर द पार्ट ऑफ द लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप पता चल गया
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का हम पार्ट हैं। नेक्स्ट
उसके बाद हम क्या करना है? हमें अपना लेवल
चेक लेवल चेक करना है। लेवल चेक करने के
लिए हु एम आई। उसके बाद
ग्रुप्स
देन उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे? फाइंड
लेबल हिट एंटर तो हमारा लेवल कौन सा है?
मीडियम मीडियम इंटीग्रिटी लेवल हमारा तो
आपको पता चल गया हमें क्या करना है? हाई
में कन्वर्ट करना है। हाई में कन्वर्ट
करने के लिए आपको पता है क्या करना है?
सबसे पहले आपको पहली कमांड कौन सी करनी
थी? रन सेट उसके बाद रजिस्ट्री अंडरस्कोर
की। उसके बाद उसकी वैल्यू को सेट करना है।
वैल्यू सेट करने के लिए आपके पास पूरी पाथ
होना चाहिए। तो हमारे पास थी एच के सीयू
उसके बाद हमारा फुल पाथ था यह सॉफ्टवेयर
सॉफ्टवेयर
क्लासेस
एमएस सेटिंग
सेटिंग्स उसके बाद सेल
ओपन उसके बाद कमांड
यह दीन
किड एंटर किया हमने तो सक्सेसफुली हमने
अपना एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल सेट कर लिया तो
उसके बाद सेट
सीएमडी
इक्वल साइन डबल कॉलन से क्योंकि अब की बार
हमें
कमांड सेट करनी है मल्टीपल स्पसेस के साथ
वैल्यू है तो हम सबसे पहले लिखेंगे पावर
सेल
कहीं पर भी स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक हो तो प्लीज
गाइड करना मुझे।
विंडो स्टाइल
हिडन
टूल्स
सॉकेट
excp
हमारा IPपी एड्रेस हमारे IPपी एड्रेस के
लिए हम क्या करेंगे इफ कॉन्फिग अभी हमें
क्या है किससे कनेक्टेड हैं
यह रहा टनल टी टनल जीरो क्योंकि हम ओपन
वीपी से वीpए से कनेक्टेड है डोंट वरी तो
हम यहां पर लिखते हैं IPपी एड्रेस हमारा
ओपन वीpए वाला हो उसके बाद हमारा पोर्ट
नंबर क्या होगा? 44 44 हो गया हमारा पोर्ट
नंबर। देन एक्स चेक ईएक्सईc एग्जीक्यूट जो
हमें रन करना है। उसके बाद cmd exc
पाइप
यह कमांड सही है गाइज़? बताइए।
यह कमांड सबको सही दिखाई दे रही है।
और हिट एंटर। चलिए कमांड सही है तो हमने
सक्सेसफुली सेट कर लिया है। देन उसके बाद
हमारी नेक्स्ट कमांड क्या थी हमारी?
रजिस्ट्री एडिटर रजिस्ट्री एडिटर परसेंटेज
द परसेंटेज।
यह हमारी वैल्यू थी। एक्सपेंड करना है इस
वैल्यू को। नेक्स्ट हमारे पास क्या रहेगा?
हफन V
हम से सेट करने वाला डेलीगेट एग्जीक्यूट
नहीं। हम क्या करने वाले हैं? ओके लिख
देते हैं। डेलीगेट एग्जीक्यूट
डेलीगेट लिख देते हैं। उसके बाद हफन डी
देन इसको हम क्या करें? एम्प्टी देन हफन
एफ हिट एंटर सक्सेसफुली हमने सेट कर लिया।
एक और कमांड है। रजिस्ट्री एज।
उसके बाद आप क्या करोगे?
की
परसेंटेज उसके बाद हफन डी डी में आप कौन
सी वैल्यू सेट कर रहे हो सीएमडी
यही कमांड थी देन हफन फोर्स एफ हिट एंटर
किया सक्सेसफुली हमने सेट कर लिया तो अभी
क्या करना है हमारा सब कुछ सही सेट हो गया
है अभी हमें क्या करना है अपना
एक ओपन करना है नेट कैट लिसनर नेटक लिसनर
ओपन करना है हमें नेट कैट लिसनर ओपन
करेंगे तो हम एनसी उसके बाद हफन एन वी
एलपी 44 44 हो गया हीट एंटर हो गया
सक्सेसफुली नेट कैटिस स्टार्ट कर लिया देन
यहां पर हम क्या करते हैं फूड हेलपर फूड
हेल्परx ये हमने इसको रन किया जैसे हम
इसको रन करेंगे सक्सेसफुली रन हो गया और
इधर हमें देखना लिस्ट िंग ऑन पोर्ट और अभी
हमें कनेक्शन बैक नहीं मिला फूड हेलपर exc
बट वी डिड नॉट गेट माय कनेक्शन बैक
मे बी प्रॉब्लम वि दैट
ओके
यहां पर ओपन हो भी गया है। बट आई डोंट नो
व्हाई डिड नॉट गेट।
एक बार डिसेबल कर देते हैं इसको Windows
डिफेंडर को क्योंकि पहला एग्जांपल डिसेबल
के साथ ही है। उसके बाद हम इसको रिचेक
करते हैं एक बार।
अगर फुट
एवरीथिंग इज फाइन आई थिंक
हां गाइस इनको जरूर फॉलो कीजिए जहां पर एक
1000 मेंबर एक साथ पढ़ाई करते हैं। जरूर
इनको पेमेंट बता दो आपकी कितने में करते
हैं? जल्दी से बताओ पेमेंट कितने पैसों
में करते हो? जल्दी बताओ। जाओ जाओ जल्दी
करो इनके लिए जरूरी है इनके लिए पढ़ाना
ओप प्रॉब्लम इज डेड
वर्किंग फाइन
इट्स नॉट वर्किंग इट्स नॉट वर्किंग इट्स
नॉट वर्किंग
एक काम करते हैं हम एक वैल्यू को चेक इनको
फिर से रन करते हैं एक बार सभी को
भाई की मशीन का इशू नहीं होना चाहिए।
परफेक्टली फाइन
और आईपी एड्रेस मे बी इट विल बी फाइन
ओके नॉट वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एक काम करते हैं
हम इसको डेलीगेट इसका नाम देखते हैं चेंज
करके फिर से कहीं
कुछ लैब ने वही तो नहीं सेटअप किया हुआ
देन उसके बाद
इवन वी आर नॉट गेटिंग अ सेल बिकॉज़ दे
चलिए यहां पर यह काम कर नहीं रहा है
क्योंकि प्रॉब्लम्स आ रही है इस लैब में।
मैं आपको बता दिया यही एक तरीका है जो
आपको करना पड़ेगा और
दूसरा तरीका भी हम देखेंगे हो पाएगा तो।
तो ये ये एक आपको ट्रिक बताई थी मैंने कि
इस तरीके से जैसे आप रन करते तो आपके पास
यह ऑप्शन आ जाता है। जैसे हम लास्ट इसमें
देखोगे सेम कमांड हमने रन किए हैं। सब कुछ
सेम रन किया है। उसके बाद सक्सेसफुल होने
के बाद हमने क्या किया? फूड हेल्पर.txc को
रन किया और हमें रिवर्स बैक कनेक्शन मिल
गया था। अभी प्रॉब्लम क्या हुई थी?
प्रॉब्लम क्या है कि अभी तक Windows डि
डिफेंडर डिसेबल्ड है। अभी जो आपका Windows
डिफेंडर ऑफ है तो उस केस में आपको रिवर्स
सेल मिल गया। Windows डिफेंडर के केस में
मतलब ऑफ होने के कारण आपको रिवर्स कनेक्शन
मिल गया। उसके बाद क्या अगर हमारा Windows
डिफेंडर ऑन है तो क्या हुआ? उस केस में
आपको एक पॉपअप आया। उसने डिटेक्ट किया।
अभी इसमें यह भी काम नहीं कर रहा क्योंकि
मैं ऑलरेडी ट्राई कर चुका हूं। इस लैब में
कोई प्रॉब्लम है। सही से काम नहीं कर रही
है। तो जैसे ही विंडो डिफेंडर नोटिफिकेशन
आया वायस थ्रेड और आपने इस पे क्लिक किया
थ्रेड फाउंड पे। जैसे आपने क्लिक किया
आपको वहां पर देखा कि बिहेवियर विंडो 32
यूएसडी बायपा ट्रोजन सो ये आपने चेक किया।
तो यहां पर उसके बाद आप वैल्यू क्रॉस चेक
करने गए। आपने क्रॉस चेक किया। आपने
क्यूरी की कि क्या जो वैल्यू मैंने सेट की
थी वह सही है या गलत है। तो यह भी हम करने
वाले हैं। चलो हम चेक ही कर लेते हैं कि
जो भी हमने वैल्यू सेट की है वो सही है या
गलत है। यह चेक करने के लिए हम क्यूरी कर
लेते हैं। ओके हमने इसको कंप्लीटली क्लोज
कर दिया क्या? नहीं हमारा टर्मिनल ओपन है
ना? यह रहा। तो अभी इसको क्लोज कर दिया।
इसकी वैल्यू को इसके लिए एक कमांड होती है
क्यूरी करने के लिए रजिस्ट्री में। वह कौन
सी कमांड आपकी? वह कमांड हमारी
ओके
रजिस्ट्री क्यूरी
परसेंटेज
की परसेंटेज उसके बाद चेक करते हैं
इसके अंदर तो कुछ है ही नहीं
तो प्रॉब्लम यह क्रिएट हो रही है ना
Windows डिफेंडर इनेबल है शायद इसमें तो
अगर हम चेक चेक भी करते हैं। चलो हम
स्टार्टिंग से बिल्कुल सारी कमांड रन भी
करेंगे। तो या तो हमारी कोई कमांड हमसे
गलत हो रही है। तो एक काम करते हैं। हमारी
पहली कमांड थी यह रही सेट रजिस्ट्री की एच
के करंट यूजर सॉफ्टवेयर क्लासेस
एमएस सेटिंग
सेल ओपन कमांड यह तो सही है।
अगर हम अपने इसमें क्रॉस चेक भी करते हैं
तो देखते हैं यही होगा। बिल्कुल सही है।
ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके
साइबर डिफेंस आपकी क्या प्रॉब्लम है भाई?
आपको मजाक में बोल दिया तो क्या आप सर पर
चढ़ोगे क्या?
आपको यह जो गैदरिंग करनी है ना तो और कहीं
कीजिए। यहां मत कीजिए।
कुछ सीखना है नहीं। कुछ करना है नहीं। ना
किसी को करने देना है। फालतू का काम है
इधर।
हो गया। नेक्स्ट उसके बाद यह रही सीएमडी।
एक बार क्रॉस चेक करते हैं हमारा IP
एड्रेस को क्रॉस चेक कर लेते हैं।
यह रहा 10 1750
321 बिल्कुल सही है। तो इसको भी हम एक बार
फिर से कर लेते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं।
इस कमांड को हम फिर से चेक करते हैं।
Windows स्टाइल हिडन सी टूल सॉकेट।
इसको हम क्रॉस चेक करते हैं अपनी उससे।
अपने नोट से यह रही हमारी कमांड
कमांड
सोके यस और आई थिंक वी आर डूइंग सम
मिस्टेक
व्हिच इज दिस मिस्टेक नहीं वी आर नॉट
डूइंग एनी मिस्टेक आई थिंक
और हमने चीज परफॉर्म फॉर्म कर ली। देन
उसके बाद हमने थर्ड कमांड हम करते हैं ऐड
परसेंटेज की डेलीगेट टोकन कॉपी पर कॉपी
क्लिपबोर्ड देन उसके बाद
डी तो कर लिया। उसके बाद रजिस्ट्रिक की
सीएमडी फोर्सफुली
कॉपी सिलेक्शन नाउ
इस कमांड के बाद ऑपरेशन सक्सेसफुल नहीं
आया।
पैड रजिस्ट्री की डेलीगेट ऑप्शन सेट
आई थिंक इसमें कुछ प्रॉब्लम हो गई है। बाय
मिस्टेक हमसे भी कुछ प्रॉब्लम हुई है।
सीएमडी पावर सेल विंडो स्टाइल हिडन सी सोन
सो एंड रजिस्ट्री ओके डेलीगेट टोकन डीडी
एंड अदरवाइज मैं इसको भी रन करता
क्लिपबोर्ड तो इस पर भी
नो अभी ऑपरेशन सक्सेसफुल आता बट इट नॉट
कमिंग आउट मे बी सम प्रॉब्लम विद दैट तो
इट्स ओके हम इसको क्लोज करके फिर शो करते
हैं क्योंकि आई डोंट नो कि क्या प्रॉब्लम
हो रही है चलिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो
एग्जांपल आपको समझ में आ गया वैसे कि मैं
आपको क्या बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं गाइज
जो मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
वही वही एग्जांपल है
ओके। तो Windows डिफाइंडर ऑन है। तो हमारे
पास नोटिफिकेशन आया। हमने उसको चेक करने
की कोशिश करी। अभी हम चेक नहीं कर पा रहे।
रजिस्ट्री क्यूरी भी अगर हम करने की कोशिश
करते हैं इसके अंदर। फिर से मैं भूल गया
था। यह रजिस्ट्री क्यूरी
परसेंटेज भी।
यह भी खाली है। इसमें कुछ भी नहीं है। तो
इट्स ओके। हम सेकंड ट्रिक का यूज़ करेंगे
क्योंकि इट डिपेंड्स ऑन योर लक। तो अभी
हमारे पास क्या है? आपका Windows डिफेंडर
क्या है? इनेबल है। जैसे ही Windows
डिफेंडर इनेबल हो गया तो आपने देखा कि जो
वैल्यू थी वो यहां पर आप देखोगे वो वैल्यू
अभी सेट नहीं है। जो आपकी जो वैल्यू थी वो
आपकी सेट नहीं है। अभी हमारे केस में कुछ
और गड़बड़ हो रही है। तो हम दूसरे ट्रिक का
यूज़ करने वाले हैं। दूसरी ट्रिक क्या है?
हम ऐसा ट्राई कर सकते हैं कि सेट
रजिस्ट्री की पावर सेल वाली चीज स्ट्रिकी
दिस वन एंड ऐड परसेंटेज की सीएमडी एक साथ
क्यूरी करके देखते हैं। तो चलिए यह वाली
चीज़ ट्राई करके देखते हैं। उससे पहले हम
क्या करते हैं एक बार यहां पर भी कि इनेबल
कर देते हैं Windows डिफेंडर ऑन
क्रॉस चेक कर लेते हैं हमारी Windows मशीन
में सिक्योरिटी
अभी काम करेगी तो अच्छी बात है और काम
नहीं करेगी तो तब भी अच्छी बात है। ओके
शायद इनेबल हो गया होगा।
चलिए कोई नहीं हम एक काम करते हैं। अभी
अपने टर्मिनल पर रन जाते हैं। फिर से अपने
टर्मिनल पर जाते हैं। सीएलएस कर दे इसको।
कोई फायदा नहीं। सीएलएस इसमें हो नहीं रहा
है। चलिए तो पहली कमांड हमारी क्या थी?
पहली कमांड वही थी।
कमांड तो ऑलरेडी सेट हो गई। इसमें कुछ
दिखा नहीं रहा। रजिस्ट्री की क्लासेस एमएस
सेटिंग सेल ओपन सीएमडी। अगर मैं चाहूं तो
एक काम करता हूं। इस कमांड को जल्दी से
यहां से उठा लेता हूं। ट्राई हैक में से
उठा लेता हूं क्योंकि हो सकता है हमसे कोई
एरर हो रही होगी तो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। हम
एरर होने दो। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। हम यहां
से इन कमांड्स को उठा लेते हैं।
जल्दी से।
यह भी सिनेरियो मैंने इधर से ही लिया है
क्योंकि मुझे अच्छा लगा इसलिए आप लोगों के
लिए सारी चीजें मैं एक बार देख लेता हूं।
कंट्रोल सी किया हमने यहां पर फट से चलिए
कंट्रोल ओपन सीएमडी चलिए सक्सेसफुल हो गया
यह चीज। दूसरा हम
टीसीp तक वैल्यू रखते हैं। कॉपी
क्लिपबोर्ड उसके बाद हमें IP एड्रेस
चाहिए। यह IP एड्रेस
पेस्ट देन उसके बाद हम जल्दी से यहां से
उठाते हैं एक्सक
पेस्ट क्लिपबोर्ड सक्सेसफुल नेक्स्ट
डेलीगेट टोकन हम यहां पर क्या कर दें ये
जल्दी से कट कॉपी पेस्ट कर देते हैं हमारी
चीज को चलिए देखो अभी काम करेगी ऑपरेशन
कंप्लीटेड सक्सेसफुली हमारी हमारी इस
कमांड में क्या प्रॉब्लम थी? देखिए
डेलीगेट एग्जीक्यूट परसेंटेज डी हफन एफ
सेम ही तो थी हमारी कमांड।
ऐड परसेंटेज की आई डोंट नो पता नहीं। चलिए
और एक काम करते हैं। अभी एक साथ यह रन
करते हैं। यह वाली क्योंकि ट्रिप नंबर टू
है हमारी। ट्रिक नंबर टू चल रही है अभी।
अभी यह हो गया हमारा हैंग करना। इसमें
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट करना। यह रहा हिट एंटर।
देखिए अभी वैल्यू सेट है। अगर हम एक काम
करते हैं। यह रहा
एन नेटकट हफन एनvlp
44 44 यह रहा। हिट एंटर करेंगे और यहां पर
फूड हेल्पर.exc को रन कर देंगे एक बार के
लिए। या फिर एक काम कर सकते हैं। फूड
हेलपर.exc के बजाय हम एक काम कर सकते हैं।
इसी कमांड के साथ वो कर सकते हैं। तो कौन
सी कमांड? यह वाली अगर हम देखोगे को अभी
यह वैल्यू क्या है कि यहां पर हट हटेगी
नहीं। अभी नहीं हटेगी। अगर आप इस फिर से
क्यूरी करोगे ना इस वैल्यू को यह वैल्यू
आपकी हटेगी ही नहीं। देखिए आप रजिस्ट्री
की डेलीगेट टोकन कंप्लीट सक्सेसफुल। आप
इसको एक काम करते हैं। इसके साथ ही रन कर
देते हैं हम। कॉपी और यह रहा।
चलिए हिट एंटर। सक्सेसफुल ऑपरेशन
सक्सेसफुल और यहां पर सेल भी मिल गया
होगा। अभी भी नहीं आ रहा। मतलब कोई
प्रॉब्लम है इधर और अगर आप इस चीज को चेक
करोगे इस वैल्यू को चेक करने के लिए
बैठोगे यह रही क्यूरी मतलब Windows
डिफाइंडर इसको क्या कर दे रहा है हटा दे
रहा है Windows डिफाइनर इसको हटा रहा है
तो इसका भी सॉलशन क्या है देखिए वैल्यू
नॉट सेट वैल्यू नॉट सेट मतलब Windows
डिफेंडर अभी काम कर रहे थे तो इसका एक
तरीका है वह तरीका अब हम यूज़ करने वाले
हैं कौन सा तरीका है मतलब आपको एक
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल मिल गया तो ये रहा
शायद आपको नहीं समझ में आया होगा। आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा इसका जो आर्टिकल आपको मिल
जाएगा कि
द क्यूरी आउटपुट कमांड इंटेक वी विल स्टिल
गेट अलर्ट बाय द Windows डिफेंडर एंड
सेकंड लेटर आफ्टर सम कुछ ही सेकंड के बाद
ऑफेंडिंग रजिस्ट्री वैल्यू गेट डिलीटेड एज
एक्सपेक्टेड इट अपीयर्स इट टेक अ मोमेंट
जैसे मैंने आपको दिखाया। तो हम ट्रिक नंबर
थ्री का यूज़ करते हैं। ट्रिक नंबर थ्री
कौन सी है आपकी? हम क्या करते हैं?
इंस्टेड ऑफ राइटिंग आवर पेलोड इंटू एच की
करंट यूजर सॉफ्टवेयर क्लास एमएस सेटिंग
सेल ओपन सीएमडी वी विल यूज़ करंट करंट
वर्जन एंट्री अंडर ए प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी
मतलब क्या है कि अभी हम क्या करने वाले
हैं अभी तक तो हम उसकी वैल्यू को चेंज कर
रहे थे। अब हम सीधा क्या करेंगे कि जो
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर वैल्यू को चेंज करने की
बजाय एक और रजिस्ट्री के अंदर एक
रजिस्ट्री वैल्यू होती है करंट वर्जन।
क्या होती है? एक करंट वर्जन। करंट वर्जन
भी क्या होता है? एक प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी
है। यहां पर अगर हम क्या करते हैं कि पहले
मैं करंट वर्जन को बता देता हूं। करंट
वर्जन क्या है आपका? दिस एंट्री इज यूज्ड
व्हेन यू हैव मल्टीपल इंस्टेंसेस ऑफ एन
एप्लीकेशन विद डिफरेंट वर्जन रनिंग ऑन द
सेम सेम सिस्टम। मतलब क्या है कि करंट
वर्जन
गाइस 1 मिनट 1 मिनट। सो अगर आपकी जो
बाइनरी है आपकी एग्जीक्यूटेबल है। अगर
उसके मल्टीपल वर्जन है आपकी मशीन के अंदर
तो इस प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी के अंदर जो जिस
वर्जन से जो वर्जन हम अभी एग्जीक्यूट कर
रहे हैं डबल क्लिक करने के बाद उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन इस करंट वर्जन के अंदर वर्जन
स्पेसिफिक रहती है कि जब मैं डबल क्लिक
करूंगा उस फाइल के ऊपर तो मुझे कौन सा
वर्जन क्या करना है? रन करना है। करंट
वर्जन अलाउ यू टू पॉइंट आउट द डिफाइंड
डिफॉल्ट वर्जन ऑफ़ द एप्लीकेशन टू बी यूज़्ड
बाय द Windows व्हेन ओपनिंग ए गिवन फाइल
टैब। वही है। तो करंट वर्जन में आपके उस
पर्टिकुलर बाइनरी के वर्जनंस क्या होते
हैं? स्टोर मिलते हैं। वर्जनंस की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है आपको। ओके?
वी विल क्रिएट एन एंट्री। अभी हम क्या
करेंगे कि हम करंट वर्जन के लिए उसका
वर्जन स्पेसिफिक। हम क्या करेंगे? एक अलग
से एंट्री बनाएंगे प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी के
लिए और इसके साथ मैप कर देंगे। किसके साथ
मैप कर देंगे? करंट वर्जन के साथ। वी विल
क्रिएट एन एंट्री ऑन द रजिस्ट्री फॉर ए
न्यू प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी ऑफ़ आवर चॉइस एंड
देन पॉइंट टू द करंट वर्जन एंटर इन द एमएस
सेटिंग प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी टू आवर न्यूली
क्रिएटेड प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी। हम क्या सोच
रहे हैं कि देखो करंट वर्जन एक प्रकार से
आपका एक पॉइंटर है या शॉर्टकट है। जब भी
क्या करता है Windows कोई भी फाइल ओपन
करता है तो सबसे पहले वो देख देखता है कि
इस पर्टिकुलर एग्जीक्यूटेबल का इस
पर्टिकुलर फाइल टाइप का कौन सा वर्जन जो
आपका करंट वर्जन जो रजिस्ट्री वैल्यू है
कौन से वर्जन को पॉइंट आउट कर रही है और
उसी वर्जन के हिसाब से फिर जो पर्टिकुलर
कमांड उसके लिए अगेंस्ट मेंशन की गई है
सेल ओपन कमांड के अंदर या उसके जो डिफॉल्ट
कमांड है उसको एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है।
उसके अगेंस्ट क्या किया जाता है? उसके जो
अ
प्रोग्राम्स है उसको रन किया जाता है
अकॉर्डिंग टू द करंट वर्जन। अब हम इसी चीज
का फायदा उठाने वाले हैं। हर एक यह रहती
है वैल्यू यह भी। तो इसको हम कैसे फायदा
उठाएंगे? चलिए इसको हम फायदा उठाने के लिए
हम क्या करने वाले हैं? अभी सीधा डायरेक्ट
यह रन करने वाले हैं हम। यह कुछ कमांड्स
हैं। मैं आपको डायरेक्टली कट कॉपी पेस्ट
करने वाला हूं। इधर से सेट cएमटी पावर सेल
विडॉन सॉकेट्स
ये सेम है बिल्कुल सेम कमांड है तो इसको
मैं क्या करने वाला हूं एज इट इज़ मैं रन
करने वाला हूं यह वाली कमांड
सेट
सेट सीएमडी ये रही बिल्कुल सेम कमांड है
कॉपी किया यहां पर मैं इसको क्या कर रहा
हूं अभी पेस्ट क्लिपबोर्ड हिट एंटर इसको
हमने क्या किया सेट कर दिया और इसके लिए
अभी इसके लिए इसको कंट्रोल सी कर देते हैं
अगर नहीं तो फिर से मैं इसको सेट कर देता
हूं
गुड अभी सेट हो गया। देन उसके बाद हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? सेकंड कमांड। सेकंड कमांड
हमारी ये थी रजिस्ट्री ऐड। अब की बार यह
देखो जो कमांड हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। यह
रही
अब की जो हमारी कमांड रहेगी यह है।
रजिस्ट्री ऐड एचके सॉफ्टवेयर क्लास ड.tएम
कर दिया हमने। सेल ओपन कमांड। इसके अंदर
हमने एक अलग से एंट्री ऐड कर दी और जो
सीएमडी के अंदर जो वैल्यू थी ना पावर सेल
की वो इसके डेटा के अंदर स्टोर कर दी। जो
टीएचएम नाम की जो रजिस्ट्री की है इसकी जो
वैल्यू है यह है पावर सेल विंडोज स्टाइल
और यह कर दिया हिट एंटर ऑपरेशन कंप्लीटेड
सक्सेसफुली। देन उसके बाद हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? फिर रजिस्ट्री ऐड एमएस सेटिंग
करंट वर्जन की जो वैल्यू है उसको हम इसके
साथ मैप कर देंगे। इस इसके साथ मैप कर
देंगे। देखिए
रजिस्ट्री ऐड एच के करंट यूजर सॉफ्टवेयर
क्लासेस एमएस सेटिंग करंट वर्जन उसके अंदर
करंट वर्जन जो की थी उसके साथ हमने इसको
किसको मैप कर रहे हैं डेटा के अंदर टीएचएम
इसको हिट एंटर फ़ोर्सफुली हमने मैप कर दिया
जैसे ही हमने फोर्सफुली मैप कर दिया उसके
बाद फूड हेलपर exc को हम रन करने वाले हैं
fd hxc को क्या करने वाले हैं हम रन करने
वाले हैं तो कैसे करेंगे देखो पहले एक काम
करते हैं nc hfन एन वी एलपी
44 44 हिट एंटर देन अभी काम कर जाना
चाहिए। अदरवाइज फिर एक और काम करेंगे। फूड
हेल्पर
exc हिट एंटर रन किया। यह रहा सक्सेसफुली
रन हो गया। अब हम चेक करते हैं। हु एम आई
ग्रुप्स Windows डिफाइंडर के होते हुए भी
यह काम कर रहा है। फाइंड
लेवल
और लेटेस्ट सिस्टम में यह नहीं है। देखो
मीडियम मैंडेटरी लेवल क्या है? हाई
इंटीग्रिटी मीडियम लेवल। सबको आ गया समझ
में? क्लियर क्या हमने किया? सबको समझ में
आ गया?
यह चीज सबको क्लियर हुई?
गाइस बताइए
थोड़ा सा मुझे पता है कि यार थोड़ा सा आप
कंफ्यूज हो गएगे कि सर आप क्या-क्या कर
रहे थे और कुछ चीजें फेल हो गई कुछ चीजें
काम नहीं की तो वो क्यों नहीं की सर क्या
इशू था तो हो सकता है कि मेरी टाइप एरर
रही हो या मेरी तरफ से कुछ प्रॉब्लम
क्रिएट हो गई हो तो इसलिए नहीं काम की हो
अभी यह काम कर गया लेकिन अगर विंडो
डिफेंडर इनेबल ही है डिसेबल नहीं हुआ तो
हो सकता है तब भी वो वो काम नहीं कर रहा
था। समझ में आ गए? तो कुछ बहुत सारे रीज़ंस
हो सकते हैं। बट हमेशा हिट एंड ट्रायल
करना होता है। तो इसमें भी वही हमने किया।
तो इस ये था आपका टॉपिक। तो सबको समझ में
आ गया मैनुअल टेक्निक्स। अभी यहां पर आपको
एक चीज समझ में आ गई होगी। आपके पास एक
इंफॉर्मेशन थी कि फूड हेलपर.exc है। वो एक
प्रोग्राम है। ठीक है? और वह क्या करता
है? हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल के साथ रन करता
है। मतलब उसके अगर उसको हमने क्या किया?
माल फंक्शन किया या उसके साथ हमने क्या
किया मॉडिफाई किया कुछ मॉडिफिकेशन किया या
उसका मिसयूज किया उसका अब्यूज किया तो
हमें जो एक्सेस मिलेगा वो हाई इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल का एक्सेस मिलेगा तो हमने उसी के
हिसाब से क्या किया Windows डिफेंडर अगर
ऑफ था तो हमने कोशिश की उसके बाद हमने एक
हिट एंड ट्राई की कि चलो एक काम करते हैं
कुछ सेकंड के लिए Windows डिफेंडर क्या
करता है उसको डिटेक्ट नहीं करता सेकंड में
अपने क्या करता है अपना काम करने की कोशिश
करते हैं बट नो वी आर फेल्ड थर्ड वन हम
क्या कर रहे हैं अभी भी हमने क्या किया कि
चलो एक काम करते हैं डायरेक्ट रजिस्ट्री
को मॉडिफाई नहीं करते। हम उसके करंट वर्जन
को रीडायरेक्ट करते हैं अपने वाले ने अपने
जो हमने पेलोड बनाया उस पे तो वो काम कर
गया और डिफेंड Windows डिफेंडर ने उसको
फ्लैग भी नहीं किया। तो ऐसे आपको हिट एंड
ट्रायल करना है। आपको चेक करना है। देखिए
एक चीज होती है कि रियल केस में क्या होगा
कि जब आप क्या करते हो ना किसी भी मशीन पर
अटैक करोगे तो आप पहले जो भी पेलोड बनाओगे
वो आप टेस्टेड पेलोड बनाओगे कि उसको विंडो
डिफेंडर भी कोई
एक्सेप्ट नहीं कर रहा हो मतलब डिटेक्ट
नहीं कर रहा हो। ईडीआर भी कोई डिटेक्ट
नहीं कर रहा हो। मतलब आप हर एक के साथ वो
टेस्ट कर करके या टेस्ट पास करके देन यू
आर कॉन्फिडेंट कि कोई भी मशीन या जिस मशीन
को आप टारगेट करने वाले हो वो मशीन इसको
डिटेक्ट नहीं कर पाएगी देन ओनली यू
एग्जीक्यूट दैट पे लोड तभी आप उस टारगेट
पे एग्जीक्यूट करते हो अदरवाइज एक बार
आपने ट्राई किया और अगर वहां पर डिटेक्ट
हो गया तो सेकंड चांस तो मिलता ही नहीं
अटैकर को कि वह दोबारा उसको कर पाए बिकॉज़
वहां पर उसके लॉक बन जाएंगे। उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन हो जाएगी और अलर्ट हो जाएगी।
आपकी जो भी टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है
जिसको आप टारगेट करना चाहते हो और एक बार
अलर्ट उनको मिल गया तो वह फिर क्या
करेंगे? आपको या तो जानबूझकर ट्रैप में
फंसाने की कोशिश करेंगे या और कुछ ट्राई
करने की कोशिश करें। तो इसी प्रकार से
क्या है कि वही आपका काम है कि यूएस को
बाईपास करने के लिए आपकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन है
लिमिटेड जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास उस
इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए। ब्लाइंडली आपको
उसको ट्राई करके नहीं देखना है। क्लियर
एवरीवन?
यह चीज सबको समझ में आ गई?
यह चीज सबको क्लियर हो गई? बताइए।
बिल्कुल किसी को कोई डाउट?
बुक मिल गई सबको जो मैंने आपको बताया था।
मिल गई। चलो।
सीएलआई बेस्ड ऑटोमेटिक एक टूल होता है
यूएसm मी ठीक है यूएसm मी इज एन ओपन सोर्स
रोबस्ट प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन टूल डेवलप्ड
बाय हायर जीरो एक्स इट कैन बी यूज्ड टू
बायपास Windows यूएससी बाय लेवरेजिंग
वेरियस टेक्निक्स मतलब अभी तक जितने भी
टेक्निक्स का यूज़ किया गया है यूएससी को
बायपास करने के लिए या जितने भी पॉपुलर
बाइनरीज मिली है जिनके थ्रू अटैकर्स ने
यूएससी को बायपास किया है। इस टूल्स के
अंदर वो सारी टेक्निक्स अवेलेबल्स हैं। द
यूएसm मी गीब रिपॉजिटरी कंटेन्स अ वेरी
वेल डॉक्यूमेंटेड लिस्ट ऑफ मेथड्स दैट कैन
बी यूज्ड टू बायपास यूएसी ऑन मल्टीपल
वर्जन ऑफ Windows रेंजिंग फ्रॉम Windows 7
टू Windows 11। Windows 7 से लेके Windows
11 तक के पेलोड इसके अंदर अवेलेबल हैं। इट
अलाउज़ अटैकर टू एग्जीक्यूट मलिशियस पेलोड
ऑन ए Windows टारगेट विद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
और एलिवेटेड प्रिविलजेस बाय अब्यूजिंग द
इनबिल्ट Windows ऑटो एलिवेट टूल्स।
बेसिकली क्या करता है? यह उन्हीं को देखो
यह टूल की मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं
कि यह टूल तभी काम करेगा जब आपके पास जिस
इंफॉर्मेशन जिक्र मैंने आपको किया था कि
आपके पास वो इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए और उस
इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार पर वो चीज इस टूल के
अंदर मैच होनी चाहिए देन ओनली दिस टूल विल
वर्क डायरेक्टली ऐसा टूल नहीं है कि आपने
इसको एग्जीक्यूट किया और इसने आपको सेल ला
के दे दिया ऐसा नहीं है। आपके पास वो
इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए। देन ओनली यू कैन
डू इट। तो द यूएस मी गीटब रिपोजिटरी हैज़
मोर देन 60 एक्सप्लइट्स दैट कैन बी यूज्ड
टू बायपास यूएस डिपेंडिंग ऑन वर्जन ऑफ
Windows अर्निंग ऑन द टारगेट देखो मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं यूएसm
यह इसकी गिट रिपॉजिटरी है यहां पर आप
देखोगे 13 तो डिफिटिंग Windows यूजर
कंट्रोल यूजर अकाउंट कंट्रोल बाय अबजिंग
बिल्ट इन Windows ऑटो एलिवेट बिहेवियर
बैकडोर दिस प्रोजेक्ट डेमोंस्ट्रेट वेरियस
यूएस बाईपास टेक्निक्स एंड सर्वर एजुकेशनल
रिसोर्सेज। सिस्टम रिक्वायरमेंट्स क्या
है? Windows 7, 8.1, 10 जो भी है
रिक्वायरमेंट्स है। दूसरी रिक्वायरमेंट
क्या है? कि एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट विद
यूएस सेट ऑन डिफॉल्ट सेटिंग। एडमिनिस्टर
अकाउंट होना चाहिए जैसे मैं आपको बता रहा
था। उसके बाद इसको यूज़ करने का तरीका यह
है aगi 32.xe aका 64.xe क्योंकि इसके यह
यहां पर अवेलेबल है। सोर्स के अंदर होगा।
ये रहा सोर्स के अंदर होगा या फिर आपका
इसके अंदर है आपके बाइनरी फाइल के अंदर के
इसके अंदर नहीं है तो सोर्स के अंदर होगा
आका का यह रही यह रहे यहां पर आपका टूल्स
होगा 64
यह रहा 64
का गाइस 64 एक मिनट हमें देखना है इसको एक
मिनट वेट इसको मिल जाएगा। आप जिसको सर्च
करोगे ना तो इसमें आसानी से मिल जाएगा। तो
यहां पर देखो उसके बाद इसको यूज़ करने का
तरीका बता दिया इसमें। इन्होंने देखो यहां
पर देखो ये रहा वो एक्सप्लइट है। 1 2 3 4
5 अब जो हमने एक्सप्लइट किया था क्या यहां
पर है? देखो डीएलएल हाईकिंग के लिए है।
डीएलएल हाईकिंग डीएलएल हाई जैकिंग अह यह
रहा इनपुट फाइल डब्ल्यूए एंड यह रहा
डीएलएल हाईजैकिंग।
मतलब मोर देन 60 पेलोड है। साथ के साथ
इन्होंने बताया कि किस टाइप का वो अटैक
है। मेथड कौन सा यूज़ होने वाला है। टारगेट
कहां पर है। उसके बाद कंपोनेंट कौन सा
कंपोनेंट को उसको अब यूज़ करेगा। किस
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए है? फिक्स हो गया
नहीं हो गया या फिक्स कब हुआ? Windows 10
RS1 मतलब अब फिक्स हुआ। तो यह सारी चीजें
देख सकते हो आप। देखो जो हमारा था जो
हमारा Windows यह आएगा हमारा 33 पे आएगा।
एक तो
यह रहा
ओके
बदल गया फूड देखो जरा सेल एपीआई रजिस्ट्री
की मैनपुलेशन मेथड जो हमने यूज़ किया था
सिस्टम 32 फूड हेलपर exc अटैक का डिफाइन
यह देखो वर्क फ्रॉम Windows 10
1024 से काम करता अभी तक फिक्स नहीं किया
गया है अनफिक्स है मतलब क्या है कि अभी भी
यह काम करता है अनफिक्स है बट नॉट नॉट
गारंटी सभी मशीन में काम करेगा। बिकॉज़ जिस
वैल्यू को यह अब्यूज करता था, वह वैल्यू
हटा दी गई है। अगर हम चेक करेंगे हमारी
मेरी मशीन में Window 11 में यह नहीं
मिलता। नहीं पॉसिबल है। मैं देख चुका हूं।
यह रहा आपका। दूसरा तरीका हमने जो Windows
डिफेंडर वाला किया था, वह था हमारा शायद
70। यह देखो। यह देखो। यह दीज़ आर द ऑल द
टेक्निक्स। यह हमारा देखो 70
यह रहा
डिफाइन डिफाइन इसमें अनफिक्स्ड है। ये भी
अनफिक्स्ड है। फूड हेलपर exc इस अलग से
इन्होंने डिफाइन किया उसको रन किया। तो यह
टूल यूज़ करने का तरीका इसमें दिया गया है।
इसमें बताया गया कि इसको आप कैसे यूज़
करोगे। जैसे हम अपनी मशीन में दिखाते हैं
जो हमारी टारगेट मशीन थी। यहां पे देखो
कुछ नहीं है। मैं टारगेट मशीन को दिखाता
हूं मैं कैसे यूज़ करना है। इसके अंदर यह
टूल अवेलेबल है। और आप जब इसको ड यूज़
करोगे तो आकाई नाम से रहेगा। तो हम करते
हैं सीडी टूल्स
यहां पर देखोगे डीआई आर अभी नहीं है
ओके ओके सी सी कंट्रोल सी
क्लियर
कंट्रोल सी
अरे भैया इस ये नहीं चाहिए हमें ये चाहिए
यहां पर हम एक काम करते हैं सीडी
टूल्स
हो गया टूल्स के अंदर हम नहीं गए अभी तक
तो हम एक काम करते हैं डीआईआर तो नहीं
करेंगे सीडी
ओके सीडी
टूल्स के अंदर हम गए डीआईआर करते हैं यह
हमारा आका ये रहा यूएस मी एक 64 डीआई और
उसका जो नंबर है मेरे पास पता है कि 33
नंबर पे क्लिपबोर्ड उसके बाद उस कोड
क्योंकि देखो आपको क्या करना है कोड चाहिए
उसको रन करने के लिए कोड कहां पर है यह
रहा यह रहा यह सारे कोड है आपको तभी मैंने
आपको बताया कि इस टूल को रन करने के लिए
आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन और चाहिए विदाउट एनी
इंफॉर्मेशन यू कैन नॉट डू एनीथिंग यह देखो
फूड हेलपर exc वाला हमारा तो हम 33 नंबर
है तो हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं 33 तो यहां पर
हम करेंगे 33 उसके बाद कौन सा पेलोड हम
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना चाहते हैं बैक डोर या
कोई भी पेलोड हम यूज़ करने वाले कौन सा यह
देखो यह Windows सिस्टम 32 के अंदर है
हमारा
कौन सा सीएमडी
exec अभी यहां पर काम नहीं कर रहा देखो
हिट एंटर किया यहां पर नहीं आया बट अगर आप
देखोगे अभी इसके लिए आपको क्या है कि
स्पेशल पेलोड बनाना पड़ेगा बैक डोर बनानी
पड़ेगी जो आपके लिए क्या करे रिवर्स सेल
प्रोवाइड करे तो अगर आप चेक करोगे यहां पर
देखो अभी अभी भी ओपन नहीं हुआ कुछ भी।
इट्स ओके। हम एक काम करते हैं। फिर से
इसको रन करते हैं। आकाई एंड इसको रन करते
हैं। अभी हम डायरेक्ट रन करते हैं इसको।
कॉपी सिलेक्शन अभी आधी बार यह काम कर रहा
है और आधी बार यह काम नहीं कर रहा। हम एक
काम करते हैं 70 को रन करते हैं। 70
क्योंकि Windows डिफेंडर ऑन है। cmd.exee
हिट एंटर किया। यहां पर हमें कुछ देखने को
नहीं मिला। बट चांसेस यहां पर देखो अभी भी
एंटीवायरस फाउंड यह देखो डिटेक्ट कर रहा
है अभी देखो यहां पर अभी अभी डिटेक्ट कर
रहा है क्योंकि Windows डिफेंडर ऑन है।
Windows डिफेंडर ऑन है। यहां पर देखोगे
सीवियरिटी भी हाई है। एक्शन अभी आप करोगे
अलऊ करोगे। फॉर एग्जांपल आपने अलव कर
दिया। देखो अभी आप अलव कर देते हो। अभी के
लिए मैं क्लियर हिस्ट्री कर देता हूं।
मैं क्लोज करता हूं क्योंकि आप आईपास नहीं
कर पा रहे हो। तो अभी मैं फिर से इसको रन
करने की कोशिश करता हूं। तो कभी क्योंकि
कई चीजें कभी कबार काम करती है और कभी
कबभार काम नहीं करती।
अभी देखो यहां पर यह देखो यहां पर Windows
डिफेंडर उसको डिटेक्ट कर रहा है। बट काम
करता है। यह हर् डेफिनेटली काम करता है।
33 के लिए भी आएगा। तभी यह काम नहीं कर
रहा। तो इट डिपेंड्स ऑन टाइम टू टाइम। तो
सबको समझ में आ गया? आज का जो टॉपिक था आज
का जो कांसेप्ट था सबको समझ में आ गया
सबको जो भी कुछ हमारा जो कांसेप्ट था आज
का जो मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा था
सबको क्लियर है
स्टूडेंट्स सबको क्लियर है सबको यूएस
बायपास टेक्निक्स के बारे में पता चल गया
सबको पता चल गया
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल कॉन्फिडेंट हो।
सब लोग कॉन्फिडेंट हो।
हां, आर्टिकल से और भी क्लियर हो जाएगा।
बिकॉज़ आज का जो प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हुई है,
वह मशीनों की प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हुई है।
मशीनों ने सही से काम नहीं किया। ऐसा होता
है
क्योंकि एक चीज बता देता हूं आप लोगों को
कि एक चीज ध्यान में रखना जितने भी
स्टूडेंट्स इस सीरीज को फॉलो कर रहे हो
चाहे लाइव हो चाहे रिकॉर्डिंग हो प्लीज
सिंसियरली कर लो बिकॉज़
अभी मैं अनाउंसमेंट नहीं है यह आप लोगों
के लिए हिंट है डीई के लिए जो हैकर्स
एसेंशियल है इसका हम एग्जाम बेस इसको
सर्टिफिकेशन बनाएंगे एजुकेशन फ्री बट नॉट
100% श्योर बट उसको हम एग्जाम बेस बनाएंगे
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जाम सीटीएफ टाइप से और आपको
सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा बट पेड बट इतना कम
अमाउंट रहे सो दैट कि आप लोग उसको दे पाओ
ताकि मार्केट में बाकी जो सर्टिफिकेट है
उनको आप कंप्लीट कर पाओ
ताकि वहां पर आपको पैसे वेस्ट ना करने
पड़े और इसको वेरीफाई भी किया जा सके दैट
इज व्हाई इसकी पेमेंट ली जाएगी दिस इज ए
प्लानिंग बट वी कैन बिकॉज़ यह मैं आपको
हिंट दे रहा हूं। ऐसा कुछ हो सकता है आपके
फ्यूचर के लिए। इसलिए प्लीज
इसको फॉलो कीजिए कंप्लीट डेडिकेटली। एक भी
सेशन को मिस मत कीजिए। क्योंकि को कभी भी
एक अनाउंसमेंट आ जाएगी कोर्स कंप्लीट और
अब हम इस पे एग्जाम सोन सो डेट को ले सकते
हैं। एनी इंटरेस्टेड गाइस पे द पेमेंट गिव
द एग्जाम्स टेक द सर्टिफिकेट
जिसकी एक वैल्यू हो क्योंकि आपने एक
वैल्यूुएबल कोर्स किया है कर रहे हो ना
कोई टाइम पास वाला कोर्स नहीं है। बड़े ही
फ्री में है। बट इट इज अ मोर वैलुएबल एनी
पेड कोर्स। आप एक पेड कोर्स के साथ इस
कोर्स को कंपेयर कीजिए। आपको कोई भी
डिफरेंस नहीं मिलेगा।
बिकॉज़ यह सचिन सर पढ़ाते हैं इसलिए कोई
ओके गाइस और अभी आपको कोई भी डाउट है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो आप। किसी का कोई भी
डाउट है तो
एनीवन हैव एनी डाउट रिलेटेड टू द क्लास।
इसका भी आर्टिकल आपको कल दोपहर तक 10:00
बजे तक या तक बोल सकते हैं कि आपको इसका
आर्टिकल अपलोड मिल जाएगा या कल हो ही
जाएगा इसका आर्टिकल अपलोड और नेक्स्ट जो
टॉपिक रहेगा
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है अह मतलब कि
अच्छा है जिसमें आपको मजा आएगा। टॉपिक
विंडो का पेंट टेस्टिंग ही चल रही है।
पोस्ट एक्सप्लटेशन की बहुत सारी ट्रिक बची
हुई है। देखो मैं आपको हिंट दे देता हूं।
पोस्ट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन में बहुत कुछ बचा है।
जैसे कि आपके एंटीएलम हेंस डंप बचे हुए
हैं। पोस्ट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन में आपके टोकन
इंपर्स अटैक बचा हुआ है। मतलब बहुत सारी
चीजें जो बेसिक वाली बची हुई है आपके किस
में? पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन में। फिर लinक्स
के भी बचे हुए हैं। कुछ कैटेगरीज पोस्ट
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन में। फिर हम क्या करेंगे कि
पहला स्टेप हमारा क्या है ना फंडामेंटल
स्टेप कि हम सारे बेसिक बेसिक कवर करेंगे।
फिर आपके इंटरेस्ट को देखते हुए आपके चीज
आपके रुचि को देखते हुए हम बोल सकते हैं
फिर हम हो सकता है कि एडवांस पे भी
स्टार्ट कर दें चढ़ना धीरे-धीरे जो आप ने
अभी तक शायद YouTube पे नहीं देखी हो ऐसी
चीजें भी तो बी अवेलेबल या बी पंचुबल फॉर
द क्लासेस
दैट इज ओनली माय डिमांड ओके तो चलिए फिर
बाय एंड अगर किसी को कोई भी डाउट नहीं है
तो बताइए
अगर डाउट है तो बताओ तो हम सेशन को एंड
नहीं करेंगे। अगर डाउट नहीं है तो वह भी
बताइए। यस या नो में अगर नो है तो कोई भी
डाउट नहीं है। अगर यस है तो कोई डाउट है।
जल्दी से बताइए। नेक्स्ट 1 मिनट में हम
क्लास को कंप्लीट करते हैं।
और आई होप कि आज के सेशन में भी आपने
एंजॉय किया होगा। कुछ गलती आज हो सकता हूं
कि आप थोड़े से कंफ्यूज हो गएगे क्योंकि
कंफ्यूज हो गया था बीच में बहुत सारी
चीजें। ओके गाइज।
नहीं किया जा सकता। चलिए फिर एंड बाय-ब
गुड नाइट एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।
अगले सेशन में मिलते हैं जल्दी। अभी हम
सेंचुरी हाफ सेंचुरी कंप्लीट कर रहे हैं
और जल्दी से हम फिर
सेंचुरी पे भी जाएंगे। ओके? तो प्लीज
बिल्कुल सून जल्दी ही मिलने वाले हैं।
टॉपिक अगला भी आपके लिए रेडी ही है लगभग।
तो मे बी हम धीरे-धीरे क्लास की
फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ाएंगे। बट वही है डिपेंड
कि आप लोग कितना इंटरेस्ट लेते हो।
तो चलिए बाय-बाय एंड
टेक केयर गुड नाइट एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
सेशन में और एक और इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन में।
बाय-ब टेक केयर। गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।